faut que je people retourne sur la Star
Ac bref
comme 50% des des femmes 60 % des jeunes
avec nous dans un instant Houssine Mario
et Mo mais pour l'instant récap sur la
star acade regarde
samedi dernier la Star Academy marqué
son grand retour sur les antennes de TF1
la
Star Tour et si depuis la première
saison notre ami Nikos n'a pas pris une
ride la nouvelle promo 2022 nous a tous
mis un sacré coup de vieux
consultant Louis 20 ans Hassen Vincent
Louisiana Hassen font partie des 13
nouveaux élèves de cette saison un
casting plutôt bon dans l'ensemble même
trop bon pour espérer voir une
quelconque évolution au fil de
l'aventure
[Musique]
heureusement ce premier prime nous a
réservé son lot de quad et de fausses
notes dans un direct comme on les aime
[Musique]
mais le plus gros athée c'était surtout
l'absence du parrain de la promo Robbie
Williams que TF1 cité depuis des
semaines
aucune star international lors de ce
lancement et aucune star tout court
puisque seul Jennyfer gagnant de la
saison 1 est venu faire un petit coucou
sur le plateau
présents qui s'offriront à vous si il
aura fallu attendre une heure du matin
pour enfin voir l'arrivée des
académiciens au château de
Dammarie-les-Lys dans un magnifique bus
scolaire
[Applaudissements]
les spectateurs ont été au rendez-vous
pour ce grand retour puisqu'ils étaient
4,8 millions devant TF1 samedi soir pour
le supporter heureux de retrouver dans
ce mot réussit alors pour la Star Ac
même si l'aventure ne fait que commencer
aussi il est avec nous bon on est Mario
ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
allez viens viens
là on a du lourd finaliste finaliste et
presque bref
toutes les saisons je suis d'accord pour
moi
j'aime bien les blonds donc ça c'est mon
c'est mon petit truc à moi 13h sur le
plateau merci vous avez vu la le premier
prime juste un petit mot qu'est-ce que
vous en avez pensé voilà globalement
est-ce que vous avez aimé pas aimer
aussi qu'est-ce que tu as préféré
qu'est-ce que tu as pas aimé qu'est-ce
que tu as déçu moi je suis triste de ne
pas retrouver mes professeurs
et les profs ouais et on fait de nous
les élèves de futurs artistes ah c'est
vrai ah c'est toi aussi vous étiez
d'accord aussi un prof ça c'est la
nostalgie mais effectivement 20 ans
après retrouver la même prof c'était pas
ça amende 20 ans après j'ai hâte quand
même
il faut aussi de la moi je dois encore
avec la prod a fait un bon choix je
pense que casting des chanteurs est bon
et le casting des profs est très bon
j'adore le prof de théâtre
on aurait pu peut-être
avoir le comoscar clairement et cetera
bien sûr et le problème justement sur le
début du premier qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé du prime très honnêtement ce que
je vous dis un truc au Canada par
exemple au Canada ils ont fait revenir
les gagnants qui ont chanté avec un
nouveau candidat moi j'étais persuadé
que le prime ouvrait avec vous vraiment
c'était c'était quasiment tous les
anciens ceux qui ont marqué vraiment la
saison qu'elle est danser machin
l'ouverture je pensais que ce serait
vous ça aurait été est-ce que vous avez
été contacté pour le début est-ce que
est-ce qu'ils ont hésité est-ce qu'ils
vous ont appelé ou pas du tout pas du
tout alors il y a eu les 20 ans de la
Star Ac donc je pense qu'il y a ça aussi
qui a joué sur le le fait qu'on ne soit
pas là au début mais moi j'aurais trouvé
normal que Jenifer en tout cas commence
l'émission voilà parce que c'est quand
même une des révélations de la Star Ac
et si pas la plus grande et et voilà
c'est c'est juste ça moi que je dirais
que il y a une petite erreur c'est
Jennifer du commencer au début et puisse
duplex avec avec le Robbie Williams qui
est alors ça on va dire un mot justement
de Robbie Williams ça aussi c'est un
petit truc la vie des petits camarades
mais c'est vrai que et franchement il
est beau ce problème mais TF1 qui
démarre moi j'ai fait attaque sur NRJ12
je vous dis la vérité on avait pas les
moyens de un avion pour faire venir
Enrique Iglesias donc on lui faisait
coucou au téléphone on était content
mais c'était énergie 12 mais c'est vrai
que TF1 à avoir un parrain en FaceTime
est-ce que c'est
en fait on avait dit il sera pas là il
va faire la finale etc et c'est vrai que
c'était c'était le côté un peu foireux
du truc Serge Lama aussi voilà c'est les
deux pas se déplacer les deux points
négatifs c'était ça c'est les trucs en
zoom où on se disait bon
ça faisait vraiment petit moyen déjà il
y a ça et puis il y a aussi je veux dire
une star ac 100 star international sans
même star française qui viennent chanter
avec les élèves c'est d'accord mais
c'est pas pareil elle vient après comme
l'a dit Mario elle vient après mais tout
le prime
de TF1 pardon qui voulait vraiment
mettre en avant les candidats c'est la
découverte du nouveau candidats comme
chaque année comme chaque année de là
c'est vrai que les gens qui ont mon âge
un peu s'attendait c'était compliqué
pour TF1 il fallait les nouveautés pour
les jeunes qui connaissent pas les
anciens et il fallait un peu de
nostalgie pour les plus en plus anciens
un petit scoop quand même pour les
spectateurs qui nous regardent c'est que
vous allez quasiment tous être intégré à
Star Academy parce que je crois que
notamment demain soir dimanche soir
peut-être en tout cas vous avez des
dîners au château avec les nouveaux
candidats c'est ça mario c'est un point
important moi j'y vais demain tu vas
demain demain ouais tout à fait et ça va
faire bizarre parce que 21 ans après j'y
suis pas retourné depuis plus de 20 ans
ou peut-être il y a 15 ans à la star
acade je pense que ça va faire quelque
chose dormir là-bas non je pense pas
[Musique]
non je pense pas encore mais c'est
possible
c'est une histoire d'amour et un autre
scoop aussi est-ce qu'ils vont chanter
avec des anciens candidats qui vont y
aller demain la réponse c'est dans un
instant restez bien avec nous à tout de
suite comme Nico je tombe sur moi
la vulgarité des gens de TF1 qu'est-ce
que tu as pensé de ce problème en tant
que petit vieux je vais regarder tes
enfants ouais j'ai regardé je l'ai
regardé j'ai bien aimé je suis pas un
grand fan des émissions musicales à la
télé parce que voilà j'aime pas trop je
suis pas fan de ce type de là
j'ai trouvé des candidats absolument
incroyable je suis même étonné qu'il y
ait une telle qualité je sais pas
comment dire les profs peuvent les
améliorer tu as 13 gagnants je suis
potentiel
ils sont tous formidables
et deuxièmement que j'ai trouvé moi
contrairement à une critique que j'ai
entendu Nico comme d'habitude une Rolls
très bien à sa place et faisons
un mariage
couteau pendant les premiers
mariage peut-être que tu attends devrait
t'alimenter j'ai un petit et j'ai un
tout petit regret notamment sur les
trois quatre premières chansons j'ai
déjà dit ce que je pensais que la
programmation musicale je la comprends
pas très bien il faut que ça manquait de
de de trucs de hit fort quoi tu as
raison
j'aime les filles troisième chanson
voilà ils auraient dû inverser alors
juste un petit mot parce
qu'effectivement tu as dit un truc très
intéressant sur sur sur Oui sur le
casting effectivement c'est le même
casting que ceux qui ont fait The Voice
sont les mêmes qui ont cassé et c'est
vrai une caster pardon et c'est vrai que
ce que je vous propose qu'on regarde un
petit peu justement un clip sur tous les
candidats et après derrière c'est vrai
qu'on va se poser la question il y avait
à l'époque des gens Pascal enfin des
gens qui étaient là qu'il fallait amener
là on l'a pas amené là on l'a amené là
Jean-Pascal mais là c'est le mec démarre
ici qu'est-ce qu'on va faire deux au
bout du huitième prime c'est un peu
compliqué disons que six semaines donc
fallait déjà prendre ça
mais déjà en train de semaine ils ont
pas fait des stars de tout le monde
c'est sur les candidats si je peux
revenir dessus ou je te rejoins Laurent
c'est que faut voir déjà le
professionnalisme des jeunes ils savent
la caméra comment faire passer comment
chanter ils ont toutes les attitudes
déjà des stars ils sont formatés
c'est très important que tu dis
effectivement c'est que les jeunes
maintenant connaissent la télévision
chaude c'est peut-être qu'il va manquer
en tout cas ça manque pas sur la
quotidienne vu les audiences regardez
les élèves
[Musique]
je rêvais
ma réalité
[Musique]
là je veux la vie des pros ou sinon
tu as des plus complets
pour toi le niveau des candidats que tu
en penses le niveau est haut et
effectivement
trop par rapport à ce que vous
connaissez de nos de nos années c'est
vrai que le problème commence fort après
moi c'est le casting professionnel qui
me dérange avant pourquoi je suis
d'accord
candidats c'est un peu une critique que
j'avais émise sur The Voice vous avez et
je sais qu'on va me tomber dessus vous
avez des candidats qui chantent mieux
que le jury et comment ce jury
en général la prof de théâtre c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais réussi à être
acteur donc c'est quand même toujours
c'est un acteur raté
mais en tout cas il s'est enseigné mais
c'est
de la pédagogie mais c'est façon de
passer ça
[Rires]
elle n'est pas connu et preuve de danse
non plus donc on peut pas demander
ce marché
pour les gens qui sont payés on peut pas
couper les stars que Mathieu
mais c'est qu'en fait il y a un truc et
je suis d'accord avec Houcine c'est que
moi pourquoi j'ai aimé la star academ à
20 ans c'est parce que je pouvais
m'identifier un peu aux élèves c'est à
dire qu'il chantait pas tous super bien
là ils sont formatés album studio moi je
me rappelle d'un petit Patchi d'un
George Alain de beaucoup d'autres tu
regardais tu disais bah je pourrais
peut-être être sur la scène moi aussi et
là même quand tu regardes la quotidienne
bah non ok ça marche donc je peux être
que ce que je dis ça vaut rien mais tu
regardes la quotidienne ils connaissent
tout par cœur ils font ça
on va regarder justement maintenant les
évaluations maintenant parce que les
fameux évaluations mercredi on voit que
le niveau parfois ça entraîne beaucoup
d'émotion il y a ce qu'on aime aussi il
y en a qui pleure il y en a qui oublie
les paroles
voilà ce qu'on veut aussi et derrière
j'aimerais aussi avoir votre avis sur
votre avis qui va gagner mais souvent
enfin pardon mais on sent la bonne
personne parfois on sait déjà regardez
déjà donc la compil sur l'évaluation
je joue avec les filles mais moi je ne
prends pas mon [ __ ] mais moi mais moi
j'accélère aurait été rides pour que tes
propos tête et disparaît
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe en fait Louis
tellement
que en fait j'ai pas vu m'exprimer
rassemble-toi et quand tu reviens tard
avec toi-même et tu reviens avec le
sourire
seulement
je pouvais les manquer
oh là là
les bouleversante cette fille c'est un
truc de fou c'est
[Musique]
je pouvais leur manquer
cette semaine c'est Hassen à Nice et
Julien voilà je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez sur des gens qu'on a retenu moi
je voudrais pas qui mais des gens que je
connais j'ai retenu leur prénom et
d'autres non ça s'appelle aussi une
polémique est née parce que là celle qui
chante très bien qu'on vient de voir les
ancienne
élève de la cheveux rouge donc déjà on
dit du piston
on peut toute la journée
et station et il y a la petite Léa qui
regarde et il y a une autre élève qui
lui dit oh mais c'est marrant c'était ta
prof parce que son frère il me dit
c'était ta prof et là je mets pas du
tout ça allait toujours je suis encore
son élève depuis hyper longtemps et sur
le prime c'est un peu non mais sur le
prime quand Nico c'était là il a bien
fait attention à utiliser le passé du
genre vous avez été élève schéma j'avoue
que la prof qui dit tu es là toi
et on m'a rien dit ça
mais c'est pas grave c'est rigolo louper
pour Léa mais par contre elle l'a pas
dit pour Anisha ça encore une fois c'est
public qu'il a raconté dans son numéro
d'hier ils ont retrouvé une vidéo postée
par la prof sur Youtube non on voit
Anisha à côté d'elle qui fait partie de
ses élèves de la symphonie je sais pas
quoi dire non pas du tout qui prend des
cours de chantier
là partout après à la télé
de chanteurs qui sont professionnels qui
ont déjà fait des comédies musicales et
tout ce qui était pas notre carte
là c'est une promotionnel
ça change tout Enola aussi Enola aussi
absolument qu'est-ce que vous pensez le
directeur
ça voulait mais parce que c'est assez
beaucoup plus calme ce que vous avez
connu Alexia et un peu plus ouais un peu
plus de point et là aussi dis-moi que tu
as Michael Goldman en face de toi tu
respectes quand il te parle
quand il a créé
c'est juste après pendant My Space donc
nous quand on est sorti de star acade on
faisait de la promo aussi parce que
quand vous faites quand vous sortez de
vous quitter votre star ac il y a
l'année d'après qui se déroule et donc
vous ne pouvez pas venir faire votre
promo je l'avais dit la dernière fois et
donc du coup on se défendait sur MySpace
en plus de notre maison disque et il a
créé My Major Company
en directeur j'aurais aimé
quelqu'un qui quelqu'un de charismatique
qui a un mec comme Louvain qui était
bien sûr
il a découvert une tonne d'artistes
attention
les années 60 non Michael Goldman et
producteur et créateur du OK et je pense
que en plus on parle de télé donc si on
veut faire de la télé
moi je pense qu'il faut être honnête si
les gens veulent regarder la star pour
retrouver ce qu'il y avait il y avait 20
ans d'ici faut pas regarder d'accord on
est en 2022 les gens ils sont à l'aise
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a Tik Tok il y
a machin ils sont sur leur téléphone
depuis des années ma fille elle a 12 ans
elle fait pareil je veux dire ils sont à
l'aise la caméra donc forcément et puis
un casting qui est qui est très bien
savent pas tous danser ça pas tous
chanter juste donc je pense qu'il y aura
une évolution
je suis malade moi pour moi c'est la
nouvelle Chimène Badi c'est à dire qu'il
y avait tenues en cours dedans ça va
être nul au sport
évaluation
mais elle est formidable
est-ce que tu te souviens d'évaluation
qui t'ont vraiment marqué qui t'ont
blessé ou c'est très dur parce qu'il
faut chanter il faut danser est-ce que
tu peux
c'est hyper difficile stress et j'ai le
souvenir un jour où j'arrive et puis
j'avais oublié qu'il y avait des caméras
et je connaissais pas la chanson
clairement comme d'habitude et je leur
disais mais pourtant j'ai travaillé
tellement oh j'ai tellement travaillé
toute la nuit et là ils m'ont dit arrête
un petit peu de te [ __ ] de nous et du
coup je me suis faite de faire passer un
petit peu le truc et ça a été nominé
forcément
dans le mag comment ils peuvent être un
petit peu dans les évaluations moi j'ai
une anecdote que je fais la star sur
NRJ12 c'est que ils étaient gamins ils
avaient 17 18 ans à peu près donc c'est
une autre génération et à jour on va
tout ça a été coupé on va et on leur dit
ah là dans le château tout ça et je vous
préviens cette semaine la star qui
arrive tu chantes avec Patrick Bruel et
là
papa
ou 50 ans il a 60 ans maintenant mais
c'est une arme star mais les membres 18
ans donc après une fois que ça dans le
plateau
c'est pas vrai
mais c'est ce qui manque sur cette
nouvelle
générations qui connaissait que le rap
et qui n'avait jamais entendu parler de
Céline Dion Céline Dion
je reviens à toi regardez je te manque
comme les profs peuvent être un petit
peu qui sont bons les profs parce que
justement la télé c'est du chaud il
fallait que mes envois
merci on n'est pas dans le sable merci
Julien parce que là si je suis vachement
investie
[Rires]
7 8
dans la tête si tu veux la prochaine
fois non mais tu vas regarde tu viens
mais vas-y bye vas-y non mais tu sais
que c'est super mal poli en vrai ah
ouais bah non tu l'as jamais dit
sérieusement bah en fait quand tu es
dans un cours tu vois ça fait un peu je
te fais chier tu es fatigué
[Applaudissements]
la prof d'expression scénique elle lui
dit enlève tes et ils sont quand même en
débriefing ils ont joué la veille nous
on était pire que ça on était dans la
machine de guerre donc je trouve ça tout
much et là à part de moi et là Yanis bye
quand on est en cours de chant et que
vous bâiller ça prouve que vous respirez
ça fait partie des techniques
[Musique]
c'est pour ça Rome les amis les anciens
profs un petit peu
rendez-vous
à très bien public remettez-moi
et les choses avancent quand même oui
Isabelle quelque chose c'est que après
dans le bus il se passe rien et là on
voit la texture
quand même alors selon vous quand même
qui va gagner là c'est vraiment à votre
avis qui va gagner Mario alors moi mon
coup de cœur c'est Anisha donc il va
gagner selon toi mais euh
celle qui a compris la stratégie c'est
et Nola c'est Enola alors attends
en finale pour moi
pour moi la finale c'est Enola et
Stanislas
j'adore un vrai débat politique chez
vous si je Matthieu
et tout ça dites-nous selon vous qui va
gagner vraiment mon coup de cœur pour
moi en finale c'est c'est Anisha et
Louis voilà moi je veux savoir alors
donc le gagnant pour toi Enola pourquoi
gagnant
[Rires]
Guillaume c'est mon associé je passe à
10h par jour avec lui donc voilà je suis
pas contre moi débile mais moi je dis
parce que c'est on s'en fout ils savent
ça ils sont tous bien c'est autre chose
d'être chanteur c'est un physique elle
est sexy elle danse bien etc c'est
quelqu'un un producteur peut s'appuyer
sur elle avait gagné à l'époque et tu
vois
celle que je préfère c'est carrelages
non mais avec ton oeil de producteur qui
va gagner selon les pâtes de musique
c'est la plus complète moi je dis
j'appuie ce que dit Mario à Nisha pour
une raison simple c'est que non
seulement elle chante super bien mais en
plus il y a un côté très
émouvanté moi qui a grandi ici avec une
enfant très dur elle a eu son bac à 15
ans
alors Léa c'est la Queen Bee du truc et
j'ai l'impression qu'elle va se révéler
en fait
en finaliste en finale je veux aller à
contre Stanislas et toi Léa contrat
nicha alors moi je vous surprendre mais
pour moi le gagnant il est évident parce
que les gens aiment les histoires ce
garçon était à la campagne il se dit un
petit peu différent il a souffert il
était on connaît tous son prénom on le
reconnaît tous dans la quotidienne tout
le monde connaît son prénom pour moi
Louis va gagner parce qu'il a touché
The Voice on nomme
a gagné
on parle pas de forcement du meilleur on
parle de celui qui va pour l'histoire
pour voter c'est pas de champ meilleurs
qui gagne sinon tu aurais gagné regarde
les gagnants merci mais non non mais
voilà c'est pour ça que je demande de
comparer parce que là dans les arguments
que vous donnez on parle de télé et moi
je parle d'artistique ah oui non son
numéro
c'est une émission de télé c'est tout
mais bon
chanteuse on l'aurait su quand même
attention alors Magali chante bien et là
vous êtes en train de me dire que Anisha
chante bien bah oui mais bien sûr que
oui vous avez été pris par l'émotion et
il arrête c'est un grand débat
c'est pas faux en tout cas j'adore
j'adore ça fait pas tu vas revenir parce
que tu es excellent dans l'analyse c'est
c'est une réalité alors un petit mot
quand même dimanche tu vas dîner avec
eux je vais dormir avec eux
il est
passé de dormir entre Carla et Nolan
mode tu vois aussi dans le château je
sais pas ça pour parler pourquoi tu
demandes de l'oseille
tu es payé pour le faire vous savez que
hein
la caméra sur lui
je profite d'aller avec mes enfants au
Louvre d'accord au château dimanche
[Musique]
c'est en discussion discussion aussi
d'accord vous savez que Jean-Pascal
était prévu d'y aller mais il veut pas y
aller parce qu'il va pas lui donner deux
œil excusez-moi
non mais non
je l'adore si nous regarde Jean-Pascal
il a twitté mais des horreurs surtout le
prime en mattarant tout le prime mais
quand j'ai dit viens on parle je veux
pas
[Applaudissements]
il vous embrasse j'ai eu tout à l'heure
parce que vous avez tout à l'heure
et qui viennent un petit peu
surprise et en live mon JP voilà dans un
instant va recevoir Natacha Amal que
j'adore interview vérité vous allez voir
les caches elle parle de tout le temps
de remercier nos invités de rappeler que
aussi
alors sur on reprend le spectacle Star
Ac come back avec les anciens à partir
du 6 novembre 6 Vendeuvre et puis moi je
suis sur scène à partir du 29 octobre
jusqu'au 23 décembre avec ou si ni ses
amis chantent Disney à travers toute la
France
mode
on te retrouve où chez toi non
allez dans un petit théâtre qui
s'appelle le théâtre la boussole où je
fais un spectacle pour les enfants qui
s'appelle la fille des comptines
et Mario Mario et selfie tu sais quoi
Mario et même un clip c'est plus simple
allez c'est parti
je suis là tu cours
que veux-tu de nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour m'amuser pour me faire plaisir
monter un peu sur scène mais tu as bien
raison avec beaucoup de plaisir voilà tu
as bien raison merci à tous les trois
réclame sur